hey everyone and today we have the
samsung galaxy s22 ultra this is the
real deal s22 ultra in burgundy it's
beautiful on hand and on camera as well
and let's talk about the display it's
6.8 inches long and it is amazing to
look at the colors are super vibrant on
this thing and things i can't wait to
play games on it it has a 120 hertz
display which we'll show here in a
minute all right watch the smoothness so
for screen refresh rates we have two
options the first one is that standard
and do obviously give us a longer
battery life at 60hz and the second one
which is what we're going for today is
the adaptive which goes up to 120 hertz
by adaptive it means that you have a
variable refresh rate so say if you're
playing fortnite at 90hz it will adjust
to 90 hertz and if you have another game
at 120 hertz it will just accordingly so
it's pretty nifty to have and for the
skeptics out there this is the real deal
s2 ultra no photoshopping no video
manipulation nothing this is the real
deal other things to know about the
phone it runs a snapdragon 8 gen 1 for
its
this is the 128 gig model with 8 gigs of
ram however the 256 and 512 gig models
have 12 gigs of ram so you think you
have those options available for you
that's y560 and 5g so you know
connectivity is going to be quick and
steady and it runs a 5 000 milliamp hour
battery so what we're going to do right
now is find out the base temperature of
the phone and from there we're going to
keep playing game after game of the game
and find out what the final temperature
is like and basically just put this
phone through its paces and to its limit
so let's see what we can do
all right that's 33.4 degrees celsius
and that's 92.1 degrees fahrenheit so
right now we're at the samsung game
center and we have 57
so let's just see how long this can last
and let's start with
genji impact right off the bat this
phone is really light and thin but i
have to say that that's buzzing with a
bigger hand you know i'm used to holding
heftier things like a gaming controller
but i guess a phone case or a gaming pad
would solve that so let's get into the
game and show you the settings we have
right so let's check the settings out
for tension everything should be on high
yup everything's on high 60 fps and we
are good to go
so let's just jump into the abyss real
quick and see how this pans out with
combat
so let's take a closer look at jean you
can see the shaders are working with the
lights reflecting off the metal pieces
of the cape you know eyes are glistening
and
yeah it's a she looks really good here
so let's just see how this pants are in
combat
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
very minimal frame rate drops
like against it feels like genji you
know it feels really good to play on
this thing
frame rate drops are pretty much at a
minimum but you can't see them once in a
while but they're not exactly like super
noticeable or anything
and the game plays great
[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's get genuine quick and
just push them off the edge
yep just like that
so final thoughts on genjian there are
little frame starters here and there but
it's nothing to be concerned about
because the game plays really well it's
really smooth
as far as i'm concerned so yeah i'm
having a good time
the foam feels a little warm right now
but the thing is that's normal with most
phones because genjin is a very taxing
game
36.5 degrees celsius
97.71 degrees fahrenheit go with your
hands yeah it could be my hands as well
but the thing is like you know all you
players out there know that it
definitely takes a toll on the phone so
you know it's to be expected but nothing
too alarming right so call mobile
looking up right now it's a hands-on
looking game and it goes a handsome man
let's check the settings real quick
graphics and graphic qualities at very
high frame rates at the max
beta royale now let's just board the
multiplayer is the easiest depth of
field anti-aliasing blue ragdoll
everything is going to be on
and let's just
get into a game all right let's jump in
and get some frags
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's cool
[Applause]
just like you know it will take some
time to get used to the controls and
anything since like the screen is so
wide but it is absolutely sunny look at
the shaders look at the glistening off
the scope and the rifle it looks really
pretty
it's a damn good looking game
[Music]
nice
so this because i've been everything
right this sounds amazing it's so loud
but it's not overpowering or anything
[Applause]
speakers are at the bottom of the phone
so the thing is if you're going to play
games like this i
honestly guess you'd be better off using
headphones obviously
but honestly but it sounds really great
i'm going to put the volume at the
loudest and oh my god it is loud but it
is clear
[Music]
i gotta say the sound is
huge it's crisp it's clean and it's loud
so whether you guys are playing games
watching movies or even playing music on
your phone the loudspeakers are
impressive that is some huge sound that
samsung has put into this thing called
mobile runs amazing on this phone no
complaints you guys will definitely have
to remap your controls in order to fit
this massive screen size but you guys
are gonna have a good looking game and
you're gonna have a damn good time
playing on this phone so we got asphalt
9 legends loaded up it's not the most
hands-on game but
i want to see how it does graphically we
have it on the
highest quality and let's just jump into
a race
all right so before we hop into the race
let's just go here look at how the
mitsubishi lancer evo looks like in the
display mode and
my lord does it look good look at how
the light bounces off the hood
the details you know
wow it's so intricate it's got the
little letterings at the back here the
boot and yeah
let's just hop right in
so it's more hands-on let's just go
pedal to the metal
it sounds really good it sounds really
big on this thing
honestly it doesn't matter if you read
the race at this point because the s92
has definitely
won my heart over this
it looks so good the sound is huge
the graphics got all the graphics
asphalt runs really well the models look
great the environment looks amazing
there's really nothing else i could say
you guys need to try this out for
yourselves all right we are currently at
47
let's just check on how that phone
temperature is doing 34.9 degrees
celsius and
94.8 degrees fahrenheit i believe that
temperature went down wow so it just
goes to show that this phone can handle
heat and dissipate it very well before
we jump into the next game let's talk
about today's sponsor here at geek
culture we love our keyboards especially
with the all new logitech mx keys mini
an elegant and functional keyboard its
ultra responsive rounded keycaps are
super stable and quiet for more
productivity there are buttons to enable
dictation microphone audio control and
emojis the backlit keys illuminate when
you get close and matches the lighting
of the environment you're in it lasts up
to 10 days on a full charge or 5 months
with the backlights turned off to find
out more about the logitech mx keys mini
and their latest range of products head
over to logitech.com okay with pubg
loaded up let's just go straight into
the settings and graphics wise we are
ultra hd frame rate ultra so the thing
is obviously you can't run water
reflections and anti-aliasing at the
same time and i love my water reflection
so we're gonna keep that on
uh shadows are enabled and we are good
to go let's just get into a game real
quick
and here we go
pubg is another intensive game and seo
fillers out there know but not as
intensive as kenshin so let's see how
this thing holds up we have the hd packs
all loaded up loaded up and everything
and wow this looks
pretty damn good let's just enter first
person real quick
yep hands so good
the character models look very pop g but
in high definition we're doing pretty
well the two times amoled display is
really doing it for me right now but
yeah pop g looks like pubg but really
clean and better so guys just like
caught mobile you know just get ready to
remap your controls for all your
favorite games let's just test out the
sound real quick
gun sounds very meaty on this thing
so yeah there's really nothing to
complain about playing this right now so
currently zooming that much but things
you can see how well the shaders are
working you know everything's gleaming
off the helmet just nice
and let's just join them in the
firefight real quick
see if you can get any kills
oh damn that was good that was fast holy
crap
well i'm dead
but yeah
this one pretty well
like i said you know you did win the
game because you already won by owning
this phone
it's really good and let's just move on
to the next one okay we have mobile
legends bang bang loaded up right now
let's just check the settings real quick
as always
everything is on high all right
everything's on high except for the
color blind filter can't really do much
about that i'm not really color blind so
let's just get into the game real quick
and start game
but wow this thing looks really smooth
all right let's jump in
right nana as always
you know for flagship phone this thing
is really carrying its weight right now
it's honestly living up to the hype
let's just get right in oh that is
smooth
all right currently we are at 34 this
thing is really holding up pretty damn
well
let's go let's go let's go let's go
there we go
noise
yeah there we go
yeah the animations are really smooth
you know things are going really well
for me right now
and i'm having a damn good game
oh nice
doing pretty well so far
if i say so myself
there we go there we go
there we go that's how you get greedy
and then here we go with the burst
there we go
[Music]
yes and we've basically won the game
not bad 12 minutes
and we won
so final verdict for mobile legends you
guys are gonna love this game
on this phone it is an absolute joy
playing on this thing all right folks
zacky here taking over the game here on
fortnite mobile let's deploy a parachute
just to run over our settings real quick
we are playing at 60 fps and our quality
presets here on epic 3d resolution come
on 75 plus 200
there we go
now unfortunately we aren't able to play
this game at 90fps epic games has not
optimized this for the samsung s22
though some android devices already have
this option like the samsung s7 tab so
hey who knows we might be able to see
this game run on 90 fps in the future
now i am getting some frame drops here
but we are hitting around the 45 to 60
fps mark get some weapons here yeah
you know what i would just be very happy
if i can
get just one kill i'm a very simple man
i gotta admit that the mobile version
does look pretty good you are having a
huge
map
and you are really getting very good
details even in the horizon now i do not
have big of a hands like zinnia over
here but that's it to each his and her
own right so i feel that this phone is
pretty comfortable in the hands to be
honest going through some little tests
here on my own in terms of texture pops
and things like that but it's so
minuscule
so you are getting very smooth frame
rates here including the wi-fi 6e that
we have on this phone
it is making a significant difference we
are using a wi-fi 6e router as well
so connections here are very smooth
it did take a while for us to find the
game though
so we are getting some frame drops here
getting down to about third
very high 30s low 40s here right i do
feel the phone heating up a little bit
and if you're one with sweaty palms
might you might be in a disadvantage
because of the heat
spiderman spiderman was here
oh nope nope nope not today
not today
okay i'm satisfied already
this is great
nope nope i'm pressing the wrong buttons
again i think what xenia has said yeah
the butter mapping needs to be adjusted
here
oh cool oh no oh
wow
that was a sorted mistake
oh shoot no no
get oh why did he like do that no
oh that was such a bad mistake
that was stupid
oh
so i'm not so good at fortnite after all
huh
oh so yeah we're down at 50 man fortnite
is taking a lot of energy there yeah
place five okay guys okay that ain't so
bad that's also bad yeah that's cause i
think we also went into a lobby that was
very little people
all right let's just uh check the
temperatures here
where the cpu should lie 40 degrees
there there abouts
39
so we're getting about 100 degrees
fahrenheit there
but if you feel the screen
right now see that
it's 42
yeah that's that's pretty hot
all right so with all the games done
we're gonna run the cpu benchmark test
using geekbench 5 which is available for
both ios and android devices so with
geekbench 5 it gives us an overall score
which we can use against other scores
from mobile devices last year so we'll
see how the s92 ultra compares to those
so let's run the benchmark real quick
right and the benchmark tasks are done
and we have our final scores we have one
two one five for single core and we have
three three or three for multi-core
scores so now obviously you know things
will change over time but at the time of
publishing this video these are the
scores that we have so the s22 ultra's
performance for single core actually
beats out the microsoft surface duo 2
who scores at 1.056
and the google pixel 6 which is at 999
and even beats out its predecessor the
s21 ultra and moving on to the
multi-core scores it still beats out
the microsoft duo 2 which stands at 3261
and the asus rog phone 3 which stands at
3220 so even though it's kinda close the
s22 ultra wins at the end but i'll say
again
these are the scores that we have at the
time of publishing this video things
will definitely change along the line so
we can only hope the s92 ultra stays
triumphant in the near future so there
you have it the samsung galaxy s22 ultra
is it good for gaming that'll do it's
amazing for gaming you guys can see the
quality puts out you guys won't have any
issues with this phone you guys are
going to enjoy long gaming sessions with
this 5 000 milliamp power battery you've
seen us play game after game of the game
without the phone overheating and i
think that says something one thing to
note is that when the battery hits 20
obviously you'll see your performance
drop and we can only assume that the
phone is trying to manage the power
output through all of its different
applications and processes and that's
all we have for the s22 ultra let us
know your thoughts about the phone and
if you want us to play more games or if
you have any other questions let us know
in the comment section down below if you
want to learn more about the phone check
out our other samsung videos don't
forget to like and subscribe to our
channel it helps us out a lot and don't
forget to follow us on all of our
socials this is inio signing off
[Music]
you